il aimait cinq conclusions après avoir
enquêté sur cette ingérence et
aujourd'hui en fait c'est la conclusion
numéro 4 qui va le plus retenir la
tension celle de ne pas recommander une
enquête publique sur cette ingérence ça
a été le choix facile mais pas le bon
choix a-t-il dit un moment donné
pourquoi parce que c'est enquête
publique ne pourrait tout simplement pas
être public parce que les gens qui
viendraient témoigner ne pourraient pas
le faire en public à cause des
renseignements qu'il transmettraient des
documents qui seraient soumis ne
pourraient pas être rendu public non
plus donc c'est enquête ne pourrait tout
simplement pas se faire cela étant dit
Monsieur Johnston conclut aussi qu'il y
a des tentatives d'ingérence dans les la
politique au Canada que c'est un gérance
et croissante première conclusion
deuxième conclusion les documents qui
ont se sont retrouvés sur la place
publique notamment des documents
confidentiels Service canadien des
renseignements de sécurité ont été mal
interprétés troisième conclusion il y a
de graves lacunes dans la sécurité dans
la façon dont c'est renseignements de
sécurité sont traités quatrième
conclusion pendant que le public je
viens de vous en parler cinquième
conclusion des comités déjà en place
devront se pencher sur cette ingérence
dans les limites évidemment de leur
mandats je retrouve avec plaisir nos
mordus Michel Jean-François Dimitri et
Françoise pour analyser cette décision
qui sera probablement controversée de
Monsieur Johnston Dimitri je suis
content de vous avoir posé la question
en partant l'émission en disant the
Johnston est imperméable à l'opinion
publique il vient de le prouver est-ce
que ça vous surprend quand même
non connaissons l'homme de l'époque il
était gouverneur général il est
courageux sur des stéroïdes le seul défi
le seul défi c'est que les parties
d'opposition
ne seront pas du tout mais pas du tout
satisfait et je parle de tous les partis
d'opposition le défi de Monsieur
johnsten c'est non seulement une
recommande pas une enquête publique il
ne recommande rien d'autre non plus à
part de faire des audiences publiques
que lui va présider donc c'est lui la
personne a continué ce processus
jusqu'au mois d'octobre et son défi son
défi c'est
d'un bar il dit l'ingérence étrangère
est à la hausse
le système la machinerie du gouvernement
est incapable ne fonctionne pas comme il
devrait le système ne fonctionne pas
comme il devrait c'est ça qui dit exact
donc l'ingérence est à la hausse le
système n'est pas où il doit être afin
de répondre à cette ingérence étrangère
et donc encore une fois ça va donner ça
va mettre de l'huile au feu regardez
regardez aller les chefs d'opposition
monsieur Blanchet je pense va réagir
demain ça va être le leader
parlementaire du Bloc québécois
aujourd'hui mais dans quelques minutes
monsieur polliath va sortir
et je suis certain que le nouveau le
Nouveau Parti démocratique va faire la
même chose donc
ce chapitre est loin de mettre le
couvercle sur la marmite sur l'élément
partisan et politique de cette question
dans quelques minutes puis après on va
vous présentera ce conférence de presse
14h30 juste un Trudeau doit réagir aussi
Françoise est-ce que vous comprenez les
arguments de Monsieur Johnston est-ce
que vous trouvez qu'il a fait la
pédagogie de sa décision
je recommande à tout le monde de lire
son rapport j'ai essayé de lire aussi
vite qu'en même temps que je l'écoutais
il y a des il y a des choses extrêmement
importantes dans ce rapport de 60 ne
pages qu'il dit parce que il dit plus
que juste je ferai quelques audiences
publiques mais ce sera pas une enquête
publique il met aussi le fardeau sur les
deux comités qui ont la cote sécuritaire
le premier qui est en le comité
parlementaire de revoir les mêmes
documents que lui a eu pour voir s'ils
arrivent à la même conclusion à savoir
cette conclusion importante qu'il tire
en disant que le reportage dans les deux
médias qui ont un petit peu brassé tout
ça et sur lesquels nous carburant tous
collectivement autant la population que
les différentes au-dessous de médias
puis les réseaux sociaux ben ils sont
basés sur de l'information
qui est partielle qui n'est pas complète
et qui semblait vouloir aller dans une
direction alors que lui sa révision de
l'ensemble des faits à la disposition du
SARS sur lesquels on se base ne l'amène
pas lui à cette conclusion-là et il mène
fardeau sur les deux comités le comité
de parlementaire il y a des gens de
chacun des partis qui siègent sur ce
comité-là qui d'indifférent des comités
auxquels on est habitué de voir les
audiences à la télé où il y a beaucoup
de partisanneries ces gens là une cote
sécuritaire vont revoir les mêmes choses
que lui et l'organisme aussi qui est
présidé par Marie Deschamps qui ont
aussi cette cote sécuritaire qui est
composée d'experts en matière de
sécurité autrement dit vous autres les
amis là regardez ce que j'ai regardé et
dites moi que vous arriveriez à une
conclusion différente concernant une
enquête publique lui ce qui dit c'est
qui rappelez-vous en parler à l'époque
lorsqu'on se posait la question tu
devais y en avoir une enquête publique
et on arrivait souvent moi je me
souviens de l'avoir dit que l'enquête
publique on aurait beau on serait on
restait un petit peu gros gens comme
devant parce que y aurait tellement
d'éléments ou tout d'un coup pas fils
serait en vie Clos
des comités
parlementaires où tout le monde a défini
on n'a rien appris non plus parce que il
y avait des documents confidentiels
aussi alors il s'en est beaucoup sur les
épaules par contre Monsieur Johnston et
j'embarque dans la théorie Dimitri sur
le personnage je pense que je l'ai senti
quand il s'est fait poser la question ça
c'est la première fois de sa vie qu'on
mettait en doute sa crédibilité et ça
pour un professionnel de la tremble de
David Johnston avec le passé
professionnel qu'il a à travers tous les
postes qu'il occupaient si je me mets
dans sa dans sa peau je peux vous dire
Sébastien oui ça a dû être blessant mais
il est au dessus de tout ça et il va
continuer à faire son travail il savait
que peu importe les gens seraient pas
content mais je vous dis que ça il y a
quand même des choses intéressantes à
lire là-dessus qui donne un portrait
peut-être pas aussi dramatique que
certains médias laissaient sous-entendre
elle est là la menace on le sait
maintenant faut travailler sur les
méthodes pour essayer de les contrer et
il s'en prend un peu au lanceur d'alerte
lanceur avec un S ou pas on sait pas qui
ont fait fuité des documents qui étaient
partiels comme vous le dites bien qui
donnait pas un portrait d'ensemble de la
situation êtes-vous quand même surprise
Jean-François malgré ce que vous avez
entendu de Monsieur Johnson
moi je suis prêt à donner le bénéfice du
doute à Monsieur Johnson sur son
intégrité sur la justesse de ces
recommandations mais pour quelqu'un qui
a passé sa vie dans le monde
administratif et un peu dans le monde
politique comme gouverneur général il a
commis aujourd'hui une faute politique
grave parce que son mandat c'était de
recommander ce qui était le mieux pour
non seulement la sécurité
contenir l'influence étrangère et
rassurer les Canadiens or aujourd'hui ce
qu'il dit c'est si
son rapport avait été écrit par le
bureau du premier ministre ce serait
exactement ce rapport-là c'est à dire le
Premier ministre est si ministre n'ont
rien à se reprocher ils n'ont jamais
refusé d'agir sur une information qu'ils
avaient
il y en a pas besoin d'enquête publique
on a juste besoin besoin de faire une
enquête sur comment changer les
politiques à l'avenir pour les améliorer
alors c'est ça aurait été le chef de
cabinet madame Telfer aurait pu écrire
le rapport mais c'est peut-être ça la
vérité Jean-François
et la faute politique grave c'est que il
faut le croire lui sur parole il faut le
croire sur parole donc il faut croire
son intégrité et ce n'est pas suffisant
dans l'environnement politique canadien
actuel ce n'est pas suffisant et c'est
vrai ce que François dit il renvoie à
ces deux comités où il y a des
parlementaires mais le gouvernement
libéral est majoritaire dans ces comités
et donc ce qu'on pourra avoir c'est des
rapports minoritaires de l'opposition
qui dirait nous on n'est pas convaincu
mais encore là le public n'aurait rien
su moi il me sort que si Johnston était
certain de ce qu'il avance ce matin il
aurait dit écoutez je vais tenir des
audiences publiques où on va contenu de
la confidentialité de ces sources là
donner le maximum d'informations
possibles tout en préservant les sources
et les méthodes de renseignement mais on
va faire venir des gens qui ont lu les
documents on va pouvoir les interroger
pour voir pourquoi ils viennent à cette
conclusion là sans révélé les dire il y
a quand même un boulot de rassurer le
public sur pourquoi est-ce que la source
globenmail auteur parce que le seul
bandit là-dedans le seul qui est qui se
fait taper sur la tête c'est celui ou
ceux qui ont donné les informations au
globet mail et à global qui devrait être
poursuivi
il est presque plus dur pour eux que
pour les Chinois bon alors moi je pense
que je pense que c'est une faute
politique parce il n'a pas su répondre
correctement à la à la soif
d'information et il leur dit vous livrez
pas les documents confidentiels vous
n'en verrez aucun j'ai décidé que tout
serait caviardé et que je veux pas
d'enquête publique pour qu'ils mettent
qui fasse même pas la tente de vous en
montrer des petits bouts ou de parler à
quelqu'un d'autre que moi qui l'isolue
moi je pense que c'est une grave erreur
Michel
pas tout à fait d'accord avec
Jean-François je trouve qu'il va un peu
trop loin dans son analyse par rapport à
ça moi je pense au contraire que
Monsieur Johnston il remet quand même
une responsabilité sur ces comités là et
il en prend pas seul la responsabilité
dans le sens où et et je veux bien qu'on
lui porte toutes les mauvaises
intentions là mais il y aura quand même
des audiences publiques et il le dit que
ces océans publics là c'était justement
pour que les questions soient posées les
questions qu'elle fait référence
Jean-François soit posée publiquement à
ces personnes qui devront y répondre
maintenant on peut décider que dans un
pays les documents classifiés ça a pas
d'importance on peut décider ça mais je
veux dire lui ce qui c'est pas c'est pas
la ligne qui l'utilise il dit il y aura
des documents classifiés ces documents
là ne peuvent pas être rendus public par
ailleurs il fait aussi l'analyse que
certains nombre de choses qui ne
fonctionnent pas et ça il dit il y aura
des audiences publiques où on va essayer
de d'identifier ces aspects là et on va
le faire avec les personnes responsables
moi j'ai senti un certain volonté de
responsabiliser ceux qui doivent l'être
au-dessus de la partisanerie parce que
ce dossier là on est obligé de
l'admettre il y a énormément énormément
de partisanneries et à certains égards
trop de partisanneries et moi je suis
dans son rapport il dit ça a trop été
politique mais dans le fond il nous dit
faites confiance aux institutions c'est
un peu ça non mais c'est un peu ça mais
c'est exactement ça et et je sais que
Françoise l'a déjà souvenu Dimitri aussi
que on fait pas confiance en ces comités
là qu'on fait pas confiance au
parlementaire moi j'ai de la misère avec
ça parce que quand on est élu on a un
rôle à jouer comme parlementaire et et
il faut être puis c'est pas de la
naïveté de ma part c'est de remettre
effectivement les responsabilités là où
elles appartiennent maintenant monsieur
Johnson ils vont nous en faire un autre
rapport au mois d'octobre et c'est
celui-là qui pour moi va être le
déterminant et oui il va devoir nous en
dire plus sur les contextes de des
fuites et des et de l'autre version des
histoires que nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui mais il dit il faut que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités et son
rôle ça va être de les déterminer ces
responsabilités-là de déterminer le
niveau des responsabilités de chacun et
de s'assurer que ces organismes prennent
les mesures requises pour
qu'effectivement nous soyons sécurisés
par rapport à ça donc c'est pas une
démarche qui se fait en 24 heures c'est
une démarche qui va qui va certainement
s'approfondir dans les semaines et dans
les mois qui viennent mais à un moment
donné quand je nous écoute je dis ben
est-ce qu'on fait confiance à nos
espions ou on le fait pas confiance à
nos institutions c'est ça la question
aujourd'hui mais le message la réponse
de David Johnston c'est faisons
confiance à nos institutions des petit
Astérix
canadien de sécurité qui laisse où il y
a des fuites et où il y a des gens qui
devraient se regarder dans le miroir il
a pas utilisé ces mots-là mais c'est un
peu ce qu'il veut dire ok Dimitri et
Jean-François vous avez levez la main
Dimitri là-bas
oui juste pour
apporter un peu de contexte pour ceux
qui nous regardent on n'est pas le
Congrès américain donc les élus fédéraux
du comité en matière de renseignement et
de sécurité nationale n'ont pas tous les
informations de vent eux
le niveau de détail qui est présenté par
exemple à l'exécutif et pas à tous les
membres de l'exécutif et quand je parle
de l'exécutif je parle du cabinet
ministériel c'est le ministre de la
Sécurité publique c'est le Ministre
d'affaires étrangères parfois c'est le
Ministre et surtout c'est bien sûr le
cabinet du premier ministre certains pas
tous certains employés
du Premier ministre donc le simple fait
que les services le sars le SRS n'est
pas là pour donner toutes les
informations de breffage au comité de
parlementaire eux ils se rapportent à
l'exécutif au Bureau du Conseil privé
mais mais on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
mettre le fardeau de la responsabilité
sur ces comités comme le fait monsieur
Johnson parce que c'est comité parce que
c'est comité non mais permettez-moi
permettez-moi du spermer moi de conclure
le défi c'est ces comités n'ont pas
accès à tous les renseignements et donc
non non je m'excuse ce n'est pas de la
façon que c'est si
le rapport c'est ce qui dit dans le
rapport je suis d'accord avec toi
Michael
a une semaine Michael a une semaine ou
deux semaines se disait pourquoi est-ce
que moi je n'ai pas été averti du simple
fait que j'étais menacé et ma famille
est menacée donc mon défi mon défi mon
défi avec le rapport de Monsieur Johnson
c'est il ne recommande rien pas
seulement il ne recommande pas une
enquête publique il ne recommande même
pas une revue judiciaire un juge à la
retraite potentiellement juges à la
course ces audiences ces audiences
publiques c'est plus selon moi c'est
plus un exercice de relation publique ce
n'est pas un exercice d'aller trouver
les faits requis pour des fins de
transparence d'accord
je vous laisse juste intervenir
rapidement parce que vous dites qu'il y
a des choses en rapport qui n'a pas de
nécessairement dites monsieur Johnson
rapidement ce qu'il dit dans son rapport
en fait c'est qu'il va l'information que
lui a eu les deux comités en question
que ce soit l'avoir précisé par Marie
Deschamps exige la course pérenne et le
comité de parlementaire avec sa cote de
sécurité ils veulent leur mettre la même
information que lui
et c'est ça le point Françoise pourquoi
est-ce que ce comité n'a pas déjà toutes
ces informations parce que ça fonctionne
pas
Dimitri même pas même pas quand tu lis
le rapport puis tu lis la logique puis
c'est pour je commence avec l'histoire
du globet de mer c'est que eux ont
partie de balle avec l'information
partielle le CRS que l'information
complète dans sa grande sagesse et
analyse à jugé bon qu'il y avait pas de
problématiques du niveau qu'on traite
depuis des mois et c'est pour ça que ça
c'est pas rendu ailleurs là maintenant
ce qui dit Johnston c'est peut-être pas
content de ma décision pour aller avec
une enquête publique mais vos deux
comités qui ont les cote de sécurité
vont avoir mon information et je veux
les entendre me dire nous on aurait
demandé une enquête publique et pourquoi
voilà avec la même information que moi
j'ai je trouve ça génial moi aussi
deux étoiles pour Monsieur Jean ok
Jean-François
non pas du tout parce que je vais être
clair là avec nos auditeurs
la preuve la preuve recueillie que
Johnston a nous nous la verrons pas
seuls les parlementaires membres de ce
comité vont pouvoir y avoir accès et
l'autre et le deuxième comité eux ils
vont pouvoir y avoir accès ils pourront
rien révéler de la preuve bon
et donc toutes les audiences publiques
qui vont avoir lieu à l'automne ne
porteront pas sur la preuve ils vont
porter sur comment est-ce que les
politiques publiques doivent être
modifiées pour que l'information circule
mieux pour que on s'occupe de la
diaspora etc donc pour la preuve pour
Johnson c'est fini et je suis content
que que Dimitri parle du Congrès
américain parce que on peut se poser
cette question est-ce qu'en démocratie
le peuple peut avoir accès à davantage
de preuves la réponse c'est oui moi j'ai
suivi les congrès le Congrès américain
j'étais correspondant aux États-Unis
pendant 5 ans et lorsqu'il décide
d'interviewer la CIA ou le National
Security et gencive sur une partie de la
preuve on en a de la preuve caviardée il
y a des il y a des il y a des séances à
huis clos il y a des séances en public
et on voit que les membres du Congrès
essaient d'aller le plus loin possible
dans la divulgation de la preuve et avec
des témoins de la CIA et d'autres ils
font résumer ce qu'on peut pas savoir
mais sans jamais évidemment identifier
les sources et les méthodes alors ça
veut dire quand démocratie c'est
possible l'immense majorité des
Canadiens veulent une enquête publique
ce monsieur Johnson était au courant y
compris la majorité des électeurs
libéraux et il est certain que dans sa
décision de ne faire aucun effort pour
mieux éclairer le public sur la preuve
en disant simplement tout ce que vous
avez lu jusqu'à maintenant ça vaut rien
ça ne ça ne vaut pas satisfaire ni la
soif de transparence ni la soif de
responsabilité et je pense que Monsieur
Johnson vient de tirer dans le pied du
gouvernement libéral parce que ça
devient insoluble pour les libéraux le
rapport qui vient de donner on attend la
réaction de Justin Trudeau cet
après-midi celle de Pierre Poirier dans
quelques minutes en principe Michel en
attendant
vous dites quoi
et bien ce que Dimitri et Jean-François
veulent
marquer comme point
mais ce que je dis pareil c'est que
effectivement tant qu'on
ne sait pas ce qu'il y a dans ces
documents classifiés c'est difficile de
se prononcer mais est-ce que par
définition un document classifié qui
doit protéger la sécurité nationale par
définition ce n'est pas public alors là
où il y a une interprétation à donner
puis c'est ce que Monsieur Johnson dit à
ses deux comités là si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord après avoir lu les mêmes
documents que moi si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec ma conclusion vous devrez
le dire vous devrez vraiment et ça ça
sera public et c'est là que je dis
Michel qu'un comité
vont dire le contraire
c'est là je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord parce que c'est là où toi-même
tu dis quand un député de position de
les convictions il peut se parler il
peut se prononcer il peut être dissident
puis il peut mais oui mais c'est pas
grave il sera là c'est ça notre principe
parlementaire c'est ça notre démocratie
publique de Trudeau vont dire que c'est
pas nécessaire ça nous avance à rien
allez ça dépend de la façon dont c'est
fait et qui donne les raisons pour
lesquelles c'est c'est bon ou ce n'est
pas bon et c'est ça notre démocratie à
nous et c'est ça notre régime
parlementaire à nous et un moment donné
il faut s'en remettre à ça parce que moi
mon seul point c'est parce qu'on parle
de sécurité nationale et dans ce sens là
je leur mets
oui mais c'est la vie
bah c'est pas la vie
le défi le défi le défi encore une fois
le défi politique de Justin Trudeau et
son gouvernement peut-être il est bon
avec les communications proactives sur
sur les grosses décisions budget santé
etc mais ils sont terribles en gestion
de crise souvenez-vous au tout début de
cette enjeu au mois de janvier au début
il n'y est ensuite minimise ensuite il
déchiré des chemises donc aujourd'hui ce
que les députés des parties d'opposition
devrait faire c'est de dire simplement
jusqu'à hier on n'était pas assez fiable
pour avoir des informations pour faire
changer notre opinion
à partir d'aujourd'hui vous nous donnez
ce que vous voulez nous donner pour
qu'on change d'opinion mais là nous on
veut tout voir si on n'était pas fiable
hier et on est fiable aujourd'hui ben on
veut voir tout donc peut-être que tout
ce processus va mener à un changement de
la façon que les comités parlementaires
spécifiques puissent avoir accès à tout
et c'est ça la grande différence entre
le Congrès américain et le Parlement
canadien c'est même les comités en
sécurité nationale et en renseignement
les les comités de parlementaires n'ont
pas accès à tous les briefings et à
toutes les notes au Canada
au Canada c'est exact donc ne rien
recommander aujourd'hui essentiellement
ce que devait Johnson a fait aujourd'hui
il a dit à Justin Trudeau vous m'avez
donné une patate chaude je vous la
Redonne
que les parlementaires vont avoir accès
à ces documents là je comprends que les
oppositions sont monoraires mais ils
vont mais ils vont avoir quand même
accès mais il y a peut-être une prise de
conscience aussi de rappelez-vous la
première conclusion monsieur Johnson
c'est il y a des tentatives d'influence
et sont et sont en augmentation
croissant donc il y a peut-être une
prise de conscience aussi qui va se
faire dans ces comités et au niveau du
gouvernement pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI